Guatemala's disaster agency ordered new
evacuations over a sudden increase in
volcanic activity after Sunday's deadly
eruption at least 75 people are dead
from the explosion in the volcan de
fuego 192 people are listed as missing
the volcano sits about 30 miles from the
capital Guatemala City home to about 3
million people Manuel Bojorquez is near
hard-hit El Rodeo and well good morning
good morning torrential downpours
overnight caused new toxic flows to seep
into the streets it's one of the reasons
police have shut down roads like this
one now get this on Tuesday the volcano
was experiencing 8 to 10 moderate
eruptions per hour hampering rescue
efforts on Tuesday the mini eruptions
triggered a new wave of evacuations a
reminder of the volcano's wrath but the
southern eruptions didn't stop
courageous rescue crews even though in
some areas teams had to run from the
toxic ash for safety this is the
military bringing more and more people
in and this is the town of elavil one of
the hardest hit we've seen police as
well as firefighters and paramedics as
well as just everyday people trying to
figure out what they can do to help
Colonel Oscar Pettis figure Allah
have you ever seen the destruction this
bad know is the very first time to get a
better sense of the devastation we went
up in a helicopter with the Guatemalan
military the destruction is catastrophic
once vibrant communities rendered
lifeless under the thick ash we also
spotted a team of rescuers working
through the dangerous conditions
as the chance for finding survivors
fades many are still hopeful to reunite
with their loved ones
Fernando stay on inform us on your way
we spoke with Martina Perez Calderon a
mother desperately searching for her
daughter
no one knows how they are doing or if
they are still alive she says there is
no pain like having to look for your
child and those deadly flows can reach
more than 700 degrees in some parts
making rescue efforts practically
impossible on top of that the rainfall
that is mixed with sometimes knee-deep
toxic ash is making finding survivors
that much harder Nora
all right Manuel bulwark is doing some
incredible reporting there in Guatemala
thank you